ein absolutes rätsel des universums
konnte jetzt gelöst werden wie entsteht
eines der gigantischsten phänomene an
supermassereichen schwarzen löchern die
jets jetzt gibt es das erste bild das
die magnetfelder am ereignishorizont des
schwarzen lochs zeigt und damit kann
endlich das rätsel um diese mysteriösen
gasströme entschlüsselt werden klicks
turms 1 im future bis dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen clixoom gibt es ja inzwischen
auch als podcast der hat sich schon ganz
gut etabliert wer also klicks um auf die
ohren möchte mit der ein oder anderen
side story und noch mehr infos den würde
ich mal sagen abonnieren und anhören
klickt einfach auf die links spotify und
apple in der video beschreibung und im
angepeilten kommentar und hier unter mir
es geht um das supermassereiche schwarze
loch in der galaxie messier 87 m 87 das
für aufsehen sorgt dabei handelt es sich
ja um das erste schwarze loch überhaupt
das von wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern fotografiert wurde
es war das wissenschafts bild des jahres
2009 10 eine echte wissenschaftliche
sensation mehrere teleskope auf der
ganzen welt wurden zum event horizon
teleskop ehc zusammengeschaltet und so
konnte das schwarze loch genauer ins
visier genommen werden auch europawahl
beteiligt mit dem spanischen 30 meter
teleskop das muss man sich mal
vorstellen das so geschaffene virtuelle
aus atom erreicht eine auflösung von 20
micro bogensekunden abweichung um das
deutlich zu machen
damit wäre es tatsächlich möglich die
länge einer kreditkarte auf der
mondoberfläche zu messen
die daten des ersten spannenden
netzwerkes von teleskopen brachten der
fachwelt jedoch auch jahre lange und
mühsame arbeit so mussten die daten in
jahrelanger analyse aber zusammengefügt
werden wohl überhaupt an das foto des
schwarzen lochs wie wir es kennen und
wie es um die welt gegen zu kommen jetzt
geht es weiter und es gibt eine art
upgrades denn die fachleute haben
mittlerweile weitere spannende daten zu
dem schwarzen loch in der galaxie m87
auswerten können eine riesige
elliptische galaxie übrigens die etwa 5
50 millionen lichtjahre von der erde
entfernt im sternbild jungfrau liegt
denn auch wenn das 2009/10
veröffentlichte bild des schwarzen lochs
wirklich spektakulär war und unser
verständnis der schwarzen löcher
vertiefen konnte war bereits damals eine
sache klar
die auswertung der 2017 aufgenommenen
daten hatte noch luft nach oben
beispielsweise welche bedingungen in der
nähe des schwarzen lochs herrschen
diesmal wurden die magnetfelder näher
untersucht und so gelang den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern wiederum eine echte
premiere denn zum ersten mal gelang es
den forschungsteams diese magnetfelder
in unmittelbarer nähe des schwarzen
lochs nachzuweisen und sichtbar zu
machen
eine super spannende sache denn in
dieser region entspringt ein
energiereicher jet fachleute meinen
damit ein strahl aus plasma ein gemisch
aus materie und glühendem gas kurz zur
erklärung in der fachsprache werden
diese sogenannten jets als ein ereignis
bezeichnet das durch die
gravitationskräfte eines schwarzen lochs
ausgelöst wird schon seit langer zeit
wissen fachleute dass diese schecks
existieren und es gibt auch schon einige
bilder auf denen sie zu erkennen sind
wie materie durch sie aus dem kern einer
galaxie herausbricht heißt also die
metapher die schwarze löcher als
staubsauger des weltraums bezeichnet die
ist fachlich nicht ganz korrekt denn
große schwarze löcher saugen tatsächlich
nicht alles ein was ihn so nahe kommt
ein teil der materie die den
schwerkraftmonster national kommt kann
nämlich entkommen hier kommt die
sogenannte akkretionsscheibe des
schwarzen loches ins spiel die schnell
um dessen zentrum rotiert und zwar
extrem schnell und genau hier sammelt
sich materie bevor sie in das zentrum
eines schwarze loch stürzt zuvor heizt
sich auf und beginnt zu strahlen
doch es bleibt ein kleiner teil der
materie in der akkretionsscheibe übrig
der nicht verzehrt wird stattdessen wird
in form zweier starker gebündelter
plasma strahlen ins all hinaus
geschleudert und zwar senkrecht zur
scheibe mit nahezu lichtgeschwindigkeit
und das sind diese mysteriösen jets
mysteriös war absolut unklar ist oder
jetzt war wie und warum sie entstehen je
nachdem wie aktiv ein super massereiches
schwarzes loch ist
können sie jetzt wirklich gigantische
ausmaße erreichen aus dem kern der
galaxie m87 und dem riesigen schwarzen
loch in dessen zentrums stürmt ein jet
der sich über mindestens 100.000
lichtjahre erstreckt dennoch sind noch
einige große fragen zu diesen chats eben
offen wo genau entspringen sie und durch
welche prozesse werden sie gestartet die
fachleute vermuten jedenfalls stark dass
magnetfelder dabei eine wichtige rolle
spielen bei der aktuellen studie hatte
das forschungsteam es vor allem auf die
polarisation des lichts im hellen plasma
ring abgesehen denn diese polarisation
wiederum kann rückschlüsse auf
magnetfelder zu lassen konkret können
die fachleute nämlich durch veränderung
der licht schwingungs richtung darauf
schließen welchen einflüssen die materie
ausgesetzt ist die um den
ereignishorizont kreis doch der weg
dahin war nicht einfach dazu der
spanische wissenschaftler eva marty
vidal der an der studie beteiligt war
diese arbeit ist ein wichtiger
meilenstein die polarisation des lichts
wirkt informationen die es uns erlauben
die physik hinter dem bild das wir im
april 2009 10 gesehen haben besser zu
verstehen
das war vorher nicht möglich die
erstellung dieses neuen polarisations
bildes erforderte jahrelange arbeit weil
die gewinnung und analyse der daten mit
komplexen techniken verbunden waren doch
die intensive arbeit hat sich gelohnt
denn jetzt liegen die neuen aufnahmen
vor und diese enthüllen spannende
details um das an dieser stelle nochmal
ganz klar zu machen
das ist eine sensation es handelt sich
bei diesen ergebnissen um das allererste
mal dass diese daten erhoben werden
konnten
denn bislang ist es astronomie teams
weltweit noch nie gelungen polarisation
und damit eine signatur von
magnetfeldern so nah am rand eines
schwarzen lochs zu messen
doch jetzt der erfolg durch ein
aufwendiges verfahren ist es nun
gelungen die polarisation der
radiosignale des supermassereichen
schwarzen lochs in rund 55 millionen
lichtjahren entfernung zu analysieren
denn bei licht handelt es sich um
elektromagnetische strahlung die
schwingt und das tut sie in senkrechter
oder waagerechter oder einer aus
richtung dazwischen dazu sagt die
wissenschaftlerin monika machine
watchguard aus den niederlanden
die polarisation des lichts trägt
informationen die es uns ermöglichen die
physik hinter dem bild vom april 2009 10
besser zu verstehen
durch die informationen welche richtung
das licht schwingt können die fachleute
also auch die magnetfelder schließen die
dort wirken
doch nicht nur die ausrichtung sondern
auch die stärke der polarisation gibt
hinweise auf die merkmale der
magnetfeldlinien und diese wiederum
lassen rückschlüsse auf das wechselspiel
zwischen der material schwarze loch zu
die zum einen einströmt und zum anderen
herausgeschleudert wird dazu der
radioastronomie vom max planck institut
für radioastronomie das wissen über die
stärke des magnetfelds und seine
struktur auf der größten skala des
ereignishorizont ist der schlüssel zum
verständnis dafür wie materie der
schwerkraft des schwarzen lochs entkommt
und der jet dort seinen ausgang nimmt
die aktuelle studie also zeigt zum
ersten mal jetzt den staat mechanismus
des jets von m87 dieser liegt in einer
kompakten überschaubaren region
verborgen und lässt einen plasma
strahler vorschießen der achtung größer
ist als die gesamte galaxie die
fachleute wissen also jetzt eindeutig
dass der check tatsächlich direkt am
schwarzen loch entsteht und zwar ein
stück vor dem ereignishorizont damit ist
ja der bereich gemeint ab dem materie
auf alle fälle in das schwerkraftmonster
fällt also ab diesem ereignis morgens
horizont zudem konnte sogar die
temperatur des jets ermittelt werden sie
liegt bei achtung auch wahnsinnige zahl
100 milliarden grad celsius die
auswertung der daten zeigt außerdem wie
gigantisch die magnetfelder am rande des
schwarzen lochs sind dazu sagt der
wissenschaftler
jason dexter der an der studie beteiligt
war sie sind auf jeden fall stark genug
um das heißt dass zurückzudrängen sie
unterstützen ist also quasi dabei der
schwerkraft zu widerstehen lediglich das
gas das durch das feld gelangt bewegt
sich spiralförmig nach innen zum
ereignis deutschland heißt also im
klartext die magnetwirkung ist so stark
dass sie sich gegen die gravitation
durchsetzt möglicherweise handelt es
sich hier um ein magnetfeld das bis zu
100 mal stärker ist als das der erde
möglicherweise hätte dadurch sogar die
rotation des schwarzen lochs gebremst
doch das ist bisher nur eine vermutung
wobei die daten gut mit den modellen der
wissenschaft übereinstimmen um das
eindeutig zu sagen sind allerdings
weitere messungen notwendig und die
aktuellen beobachtungen liefern weitere
hinweise demnach verrät die polarisation
nämlich zudem die ausrichtung der
magnetfelder die wesentlich für diesen
mechanismen sind diese liegen jeweils
senkrecht zu den schwingungen der
radiowellen auf der aufnahme sind diese
als die hellen strukturierten bereiche
zu sehen die wie eine schraube gedreht
sind heißt also wenn das licht durch das
plasma dringt wird es gefunden
die fachleute sind sehr stolz auf ihre
arbeit und klar ist die veröffentlichung
dieser ergebnisse ist für die
weltraumforschung und astronomie von
großer bedeutung dazu die forscherin
monika wodka von der ehc kollaboration
wir sehen jetzt das nächste
entscheidende puzzleteil für das
verständnis wie sich magnetfelder um
schwarze löcher herum verhalten und wie
die aktivität in diesen sehr kompakten
regionen des weltraums starke jets
antreiben kann die sich weit über die
galaxie hinaus erstrecken und die
fachleute sind optimistisch dass weitere
spektakuläre erkenntnisse folgen werden
denn das event reisen teleskop wird
weiter aufgerüstet und neue
observatorien sollen hinzugefügt werden
so wollen die fachleute in den
anstehenden beobachtungen vor allem die
magnetfeld struktur um das schwarze loch
noch detaillierter abbilden
das könnte dann weitere rätsel um die
physik des heißen gases in dieser region
lüften wir bleiben natürlich dran am
thema und mehr dazu gibt es jetzt hier
auf die ohren im podcast also hier
anklicken anhören und abonnieren
bis dann bleibt dran